we knew in Psychiatry for a long long
time that there were extremely rare
individuals that had gender dysphoria
which is as an intense discomfort with
your sex
um and we knew that they basically fell
into two categories I'm oversimplifying
but let's say two categories one were
little boys who at the age of two or
three or four
when come to their parents and say I'm
not a boy I'm a girl you know I I
desperately you know I want to grow a
penis things like that and we know that
those kids if they are watched carefully
and given support the vast majority of
them if they go through puberty normal
puberty not synthetic puberty will
outgrow their gender dysphoria the other
group of people that we always knew
about were middle-aged heterosexual men
who enjoyed cross-dressing and after
having families would sometimes make the
decision to to live the rest of their
lives as a female and perhaps get the
medical treatment so those are the two
groups
now we have a new group a new
demographic as you mentioned mostly
girls still a lot of boys it's not like
it's 90 10. it's more like maybe 60 40.
there's still an awful lot of boys
um
so this new group you know was only
recently identified in 2018 we had Lisa
lippman uh do the research and and coin
the term rapid onset gender dysphoria
and very it turned into a controversial
term and there was you know a lot of you
know
it's just it's just unbelievable what's
going on the the resistance on on the
left to fight any any shred of evidence
that their theories and their uh beliefs
about how how to treat these kids is
wrong but anyway to answer your question
this is a group of a majority
being uh young girls
who who never before expressed any
discomfort with being a girl
uh and who over a short period of time
and following immersion in in the
internet and uh social media
and most of them also have uh a lot of
at least one or multiple
pre-existing psychiatric problems
so by that I mean a lot of them are on
the autism spectrum they have anxiety
disorders they have social phobia
depression they may have uh self-injury
they may be cutting themselves they may
uh have undergone or gone through some
trauma in their life
and so these are girls and and I'm not
going to say just girls because there's
a lot of people actually dismiss the
boys and I'm not going to do that I've
seen too many boys in my office and talk
to too many parents of boys to do that
there's a ton of boys that are in this
also
so
they are led to believe that uh that
that if they don't feel comfortable with
themselves if they don't like getting
their periods they don't fit in with
their friends they're not stereotypical
girls they're perhaps they're attracted
romantically to other girls there's many
different things that could be going on
here well then you you might be a boy
and of course you get a lot of
um points your status is elevated when
you come out as non-male or female I
don't use the word cisgender because
that's part of the Lexicon that I refuse
to use
um if you come out to your friends uh as
being neither male or female it's you
know you're kind of an elevated status
and not only that but you are no longer
you see if you are a white heterosexual
middle class or upper class
uh student
you're an oppressor I mean that's this
is a whole other subject right
one with which we're quite familiar
mirror believe me okay
so you don't want to be an oppressor
yeah you want to be oppressed you don't
want to be an oppressor
so if you are a member of a sexual
minority and you know or another
minority you can't change your race you
can't change your socioeconomic status
you can't change you know you're not
gonna come out and say you're gay or
lesbian if you're not
but to say that you're neither male or
female okay I mean after all you know
we're all mosaics this is me speaking
now this is the truth I'm not saying
that this is what these kids say
you know I could wake up one day and be
feeling more I don't know ambitious and
aggressive and like I'm gonna go and do
this and that I could say oh I'm I'm
feeling masculine today
maybe
I'm non-binary
I mean that is my that was my first
thought when you joined the call Mary
yeah
foreign